Because of this experience, lukaszkalowski came up
to me when he pushed the delivery time
and just wanted to know, then you
adjusted what didn't
work, he learned from it
how we do it differently today
and then I sort of talked to him about it
spoken and then he says here
will not participate your experience is
valuable and so I came to
think about 0.99% of studienz for 3000 € so that then
came out so I think listen to it like
60 70 million more solved then
then  So at least one percent of them
over 70 million a bit
improved, um, she mustn't forget that,
but I think I
made half a million sugar out of the three thousand, but that's how it is, of
course I would have much preferred to sell it to Facebook,
yes, and that's what I have  once
calculated and but something like that should
n't even start would have bicycle chain
so that would have been one of the most brilliant
angels ever the podcast with
Christian Vollmann is a long trip
down Memory Lane so to the beginnings
of the German internet he was with
companies like i love like MyVideo  like
Jamba like studying witnessed everything as an investor
or CEO or founder and
talk a lot to tell lots of
anecdotes but in recent years she has
changed a lot into a
sustainability entrepreneur who
is really looking for purpose
then made next door and is now making
Carmen one so an idea
Producing new fuels he sees
a new billion-dollar market with a lot of
meaning everything comes now in conversation with
Christian
hello Philipp you can do that,
so to speak,
past from the beginning yes well
I started with an internship in 99 in
Berlin and that was just
the first wave  super exciting back then,
both Berlin and the internet
somehow had this gut feeling that
this digitization would turn everything upside down,
you could already feel it and
then I couldn’t let go of it,
but the pediatrician is also
really true, yes, that’s why I do community service
entirely  I did community service at the
children's hospital in Erlang where I
come from and the community service
made me realize that this health system
is really not for me, by the way, one of the
reasons why I became a business angel at
Kumi health, they
organize the
cooperation in the hospital digitally, very, very
cool company here in Hamburg directly  around
the corner okay um yeah it's not
that big yet but really well on the way and we're
solving exactly this problem that
this cooperation in the ward was
hell so chief physician nurses war
against each other and paperwork and
that was terrible and then I
decided that's nothing  for me and did
n't really know what
to do and then a friend said hey
let's set up a company and then
I'll do it like that cool but how does the
company say yes I heard
html is cool can we
sell websites that's how it was  97
and thank you yes, I can't do an HTM
element either, let's buy HTML
in front of Dummies book and learn that and
get started and we founded a limited liability company right away
and
programmed websites and sold them and I
then noticed very quickly that
we  Selling the projects is
much more fun than later
programming the static website and um
then decided okay, you're going, you're going to go
towards business administration and there you have,
so to speak, in the first generation
who you are famous for today who
attends the EU, so the university is
nearby  from Koblenz,
where then all the later
prominent web founders were all exactly well,
uh, actually, when
I took the test at the WU, I
thought I wouldn’t be able to do it,
so somehow I was told that
it was good preparation for  the test in
Reutlingen I actually wanted to
experience Reutlingen and then
surprisingly passed it,
probably because I went in there so chilled
without being nervous and
then I really
researched what we and actually
still noticed oh that is  I think it's
pretty good if you pass
you should maybe go there too,
problem, it was just quite expensive
and um my parents were always so
cool and said come on if that's
what you want to do then we'll show you
that my parents are coming are 45
born in the country in families with many children
[music]
farms and at that time could only
go to elementary school because the next
high school was 25 kilometers away and
from that they took the shot
that they
want to make everything possible for their children in terms of education yes
and that  I think that the
result is really high to this day, but it was also that
when I left the WHO
I had the feeling that I had to prove to my parents that
it was worth it and
that was part of the motivation why I
really had the drive and decided to
start a business  wanted and wanted to be successful
you would have investment banking
or management consulting, which
I think a lot of people do and who
have finished there, yes, that was just this
internship in 99, yes, that was basically
the first internship after the first year of study
and
thus ended up at Alando in Berlin by chance
that was the first exactly that
the very first what was then bought
from eBay Germany while I was doing an internship
one day media came in
the door it was different we were supposed to
start on the Monday yes and then
Olli called a week before I knew
Olli  yes not yet meant you have to
be there on Friday Friday 9 a.m.
and then I mean okay but why
but had already hung up yes
well because I was there on Friday at 9 a.m. and
then found out well I had to be
there at 10 a.m  on the day Pio
Media went in the door ebay founder exactly the
ebay founder
took a look at the company and so there were not only eight
people sitting there but 9 um yes I had to
be there by 9 a.m. on Friday
and then it was sold and that was exactly
what happened  The negotiations were already there,
and a few weeks later we were
more or less over Germany and that
was super, super exciting
exactly, so I then did all my
other internships on the internet,
e.g. at Mundwerk, Lukas
Katowski was also there as an intern  there were
a lot of interns it was the
project of Christian Weiß and
Philipprei and Christian
Schagen and so on
and my fellow students Wu all got me
so I was really the outsider
they all said hey you ca
n't do all the internships on the internet
you have to  but also go to counseling
you have to go to the wasp bank
because back then it was so ne so everyone
actually wanted to have golden sex or
Micky that was actually the
classic currency of career travel back then
and I said no I want to start a business so
what should I do
I'm not interested in going with it, but I was
completely on the outside at the time, but
then it worked out for you
because you're the first company, I think, as
if you're out, because that was already the
aylaff time, so what I wanted to do
was I wanted consumer Internet  Reasons
because I had the feeling that he can't
talk
and I wanted to be in Berlin because
maybe it was the coolest city
there, I don't know, you just
felt this freedom and you could
be if you wanted, I found that
incredibly attractive and  then I came
back to Berlin in 2002 so I was done with the EU but the bubble had
burst yes and the internet was
really a swear word in 2002 no so you
were actually almost all bankrupt there were
still two three German toilets and
if you that  said you want
consumer background got the first
kick in the ass that was flown yes that was
the topic was totally dead no clear
because the new market was the mega
exaggeration and then a lot of
people lost a lot of money and yes the
market was totally dead came Berlin  22%
unemployment back then,
we had two or three years net
deduction from Berlin, so more people
moved away than moved in. Berlin
lost almost 40,000 inhabitants per year back then, yes, that can
no longer be imagined today
and in this situation I can go to
Berlin and want to
start a business  and
it was very, very difficult to
rush the money and then actually made the detour, so
Oliver Sammer offered me
here, I founded Jammer here and
I have now developed a mobile subscription
which I can bill via the telephone bill
and am now thinking, so to speak
digital models that I
can then add to that yes, let's
think about it, we brainstormed and
said dating could be
done well over it and then said yes um do
you want to found that yes you want to
found a dating company as a
subsidiary of Jamba and
I did that with one of the eh
that means it was my first start-up
in the sense that I built it up from scratch,
but it was
n't actually my first
start-up in the sense that I didn't have
a share in this company, yes
I did  had a salary and a fixed salary
and a bonus but zero equity yes that
was really the big learning also from i
love so within
two and a half three years we were actually the
biggest dating site at that time even bigger
than Friendscout
and learning was actually okay reasons
cool but never without equity customers ne
and that was then somehow easy for you
that you build up the three
years or was that a very complicated
getting such a company behind i
mean is seems in hindsight today
but says three years the biggest
dating  side there wasn't that
much but the internet was still small
so that's actually the point
because you have to you really have to see
Philipp back then
the competition was still there so
there was hardly anyone who did it
and in that respect you could  if you
were creative then
we were very, very, very
creative, we were really very, very creative, both
in how we built the site and in
how we did the marketing again,
for example we
invented suchanne, so basically
you could do it back then  Include HTML in the banner ads
that you placed so that
you could search rectally you
can say I am a woman looking for
a man between 25 and 35 years old
in Berlin yes and then you clicked on Search
in Banner and see you then
just landed on the search
result page for this search
that was e.g. an invention that we
had that increased the conversion of this banner
advertising so much that we
could actually do it on a CPM basis and that in turn
opened up to us that we could use the whole internet too,
i.e. me  I remember I
booked the WEB.DE GMX logout page, yes,
that was such a huge format,
I booked it, yes, it ran with the
frequency cap, but
my advertising ran through it because
it paid off and so
we have one  on the big one how big
was one in terms of sales if you were so
precise that in 2005 iftde made about 2
million sales per month okay
and that was a lot for back then
because you have to imagine the people were
first of all there were still a long time  not
all online and secondly
no one dared to pay online back then
so there was really a lot of turnover for
that time and it was
also sold with it exactly that
was then sold without a hitch
without a sound will be sold
together and from today’s point of view that’s
really a shame  because um very
Sun was not at all interested in one,
no, from today's perspective, it should have been
done by management
because you could really have made a lot
more out of it, yes, but
unfortunately verify sein
treated it totally neglectfully, I then
completely  I quickly realized that
nothing would work out and then I
moved on, exactly
exactly that was exactly the time when
I thought about it, so I noticed that
it is no longer of any use here and
thought about what do you do next and
then I have the first the first
Youtube video sent
and I have no what is the Youtube
here can I upload it online how can I do it myself
and then just
watched the simulator and Alexa and stuff like that and I had
never seen such a hockey stick
on Grove it was there at the very beginning
there was no youtube.de no, um, there was
no daily motion and then I said, oh
cool, um, that’s a cool, cool topic
for Germany, exactly, and I’m doing that
now in Germany, that was
my video, no, that’s where I invested at the time
I actually did my video.de and my video
Flo at the same time
because at the point that I could
n’t keep up in fundraising,
the problem was that the
bandwidth for video streaming was still
incredibly expensive back then, we’re talking about 2005,
I know  I can't get it right
but I think I
went live sometime in the summer of 2005 with my
video and the bandwidth for the video
streaming so I grew super fast so
basically I had the
most videos that in turn
attracted the most viewers that he
in turn the the  People who wanted the scissors,
um, and I was somehow involved in this case
and then I
completely ate up the bandwidth costs
and I couldn't
keep up with Racing fast enough and
then at some point I had to make the decision
and really sort of
switched off my video for I just did
Switch off and that's actually so
sad from today's point of view because
Emotion only went online two or three months later,
yes, and that means it wasn't given at all,
I wouldn't have had to switch it off
because we were actually already
in this positive network, but
that's the way it is  the German one
had to sell quickly because of that,
or was that of course the
chance, then I think four or four
to six weeks after France was switched off,
I then
received money from ProSieben Sat.1, in
the financing round, so that I
could then continue to grow in Germany
then invested again and then
in the end bought it, no, and
that was then a period of two years,
so von Günther sold it, exactly that
was two and a half years, so I
just
what happened is that then google
bought YouTube and  then, of course, he
also launched youtube.de and then
brutally exploited his addiction market power yes, of
course you got a lot of traffic from
the search engine and then
the YouTube videos were
clearly preferred and it
always came  less because my video on me it was
clear relatively quickly that you are
doing something against this market than alone as a
small startup you have little chance of
suing the idea to be honest i did
n't come up with it at the time yes so the
row of shops and others later
did yes hello and so on
I didn't have the idea at the time, I have to
admit, and erm yes, but also against
the financial power against the computing power
and then I decided that I would
save myself under the umbrella of ProSieben Sat.1 and I think it was
the right decision
economic breakthrough that was
my first summer my first exit
exactly
right exactly and then you're out of it
and then it went on again yes
exactly you also have to see the
timing so it's also good luck in the sow
ne in hindsight it all always looks
that way  simple but it also involves
a lot of luck, especially in terms of timing,
so I sold it, I
think it will take two or three months
and so only the financial crisis,
that means it was also totally lucky in terms of timing,
uh, that would of course be
much more difficult  or
the window would have
been closed for quite a long time
and then I
took a break [music], so my current
wife Nina and I
went on a trip around the world and said we’re going
to fulfill a lifelong dream and
we’re taking a year off  out and pack our
backpacks and go backpacking
around the world for a year that's what we did back then
I think we visited 22 countries was
really great because
nobody can take that kind of experience anymore we
saw a lot of things and
then we got engaged on
the  World trip and then married and
erm that was actually exactly
right and then when I came back
I founded Italy together with David and Lukas
so again
right exactly that I think
at the airport more when asked when
you were back there can also be a world trip
called the whole time,
of course, so he was just so
Lukas and and Oliver, in addition to being hot on
my dating experience, clearly wanted to bring wood, so he
thought about whether they
should invest and yes, it was
just a good fit, yes, I knew
David Lukas  I think they're great
are still cool entrepreneurs and I felt like it
the darling
got long ne that's exactly what happened well at the
end of the day
that the matchmaking model so what
actually say Parship Harmony erm
so pioneered but not only
to one country but we have
nationalized it in 21 countries and
then it took various years
and detours at some point like a reverse IPO
now I think I also
went public no part of American
exactly but
now it has moved to the next one
exactly what for  Mark has it
roughly up to date yes unfortunately he's a
bit smudged so at the moment I do
n't have him in mind anymore
so I would say 100 million
or less more I think it's
actually below 100 million now
so I'm but I'm there have  I
sold my shares yeah, uh,
my marketing has I think 400
million or so,
uh, but it has now been
hit quite hard and tell me during all
this time that we are talking about the
time span of I know almost 20 years,
so from now again  the exit
a bit too beginner
i don't know as an intern you
made business investments at some point ne so also
very successful so your
name always comes up when you have
all these legendary moments Studio VZ
trivago everything somehow with me
yes well I have exactly I
actually have  with the um my video money
or I have to go back again beforehand
I had
[music]
at which Daniel
klein and Benjamin Kullmann studied with me that
Daniel klein is the founder of
samup and they had a business idea
with which you know  I still have
Oliver Samba at the WU and the
two of them also came along and
said they have your business, they
want to set it up and he and said
yes, here it is Christian, he did an
internship with me, ask
someone who knows  how to do it and they
told me and hey presto we
brainstormed and I helped
to write the business plan and and I was there,
so to speak, I was part of the team and the
two of them then, uh, dropped their
pre-diploma after their studies
and have the company
was founded and erm I wasn't
willing to throw my studies for
this company and then
I helped from a distance, I
sort of placed more u-interns and
from this foundation
monkeybookers came about, so that
was sort of the nucleus of  from moneypokal
very successful in the end was
very successful in the end no and um the
guys were just cool enough that they
left me a small part so I
invested a bit of money there
invested as private equity at some point and
then it was also sold because it would
be talking about relatively large
proceeds then exactly it was really although
my successful foundation
is also the basis on which
Daniel klein then
agreed together relatively anonymously in
But Germany loves the USA but is
now worth several billion and
the value of it is still a large
part, so Germany no, really,
yes, and a cool guy,
exactly, and
that's what I had there, I just had
a
small exit event in between and with
the money  I actually like that in 2004
or 5 I think I made my first appropriate
I remember Hit Flip by
Gerhard Schönbucher and Jan with Schalke
and then there were others here too
and that was right originally
in the founding team that was heat
I was my first erm  So if you do
n't count this Moneybookers nukius,
then Hitler was the first
angel investment, yes, and it was
still like that back then, if you stayed below one percent
for more than a year,
the proceeds were tax-free, um, and that's why
I always tried to be like that
0.99% and that lasted longer than a year,
exactly, and that's actually the reason why
I
was involved in many things,
yes, but with rather smaller tickets
and how did you slip into sulfur,
yes,
with
ilave while I was opening everyone
At that time, Friendster on frienster was
sort of a forerunner of MySpace
/ forerunner of
Facebook
Fenster was really a friends network
and it grew extremely quickly, they
failed in the end because they
didn't manage to
map this algorithm, so they have
the software problem  actually
smarter because at some point it became
so slow to
log in because of our own success and we didn't
manage it fast enough that
everyone migrated to the polar bear because of that,
but they were extremely
successful for a while and um we thought at the time
we could do it on the basis of the i love
Software just quickly
bring my friends.de to life, so
we did it too.
In the end we were like that, I
think with 100,000 users
the
development
that actually always fell a bit
behind, so
the usability wasn't good enough and
the Germans weren't
ready either, so it was
2003 mid-2003 end of 2003 beginning of 2004
and
to be honest the Germans did
n't really know what they were  should do with it now
so okay I know who
my friends are so why do I need
a website now roughly and
exactly in that respect we buried it
after about a year or so
the topic
but because of this experience lukaszkalowski then came along
as he as he
pushed the playing field towards me
and just wanted to know why did you
stop it, what didn't it
work, what did he learn from it,
how would you do it differently today and
then I sort of talked to him about it
and then said he
won't participate here, yes yours  Experience
would be very valuable and so I came
up with
0.99% of studienvz for 3000 € and then
let me think about it then that
came out so you can hear
about 60 70 million further the ex or
lust then so then  at least one
percent of that we'll take 70
million a bit improved no um you
mustn't forget that so
you have to take that into account but I
think I've
made about half a million out of the three thousand yes it is now but I
would of course much prefer Facebook
sold yes and I
calculated that and but something like that should
n’t even start would have been a bicycle chain
so that would have been one of the most brilliant Angels ever but that a panda
I mean trivago had something too ne
or that’s quite good before exactly
if you look at Wikipedia  does Google have you
there it says somehow more than 70 participation
I suspect that was quickly a
few more so that means there should still
be a few together look at
a few that
were particularly successful you so I'm involved in
summer
I'm involved in research Gate
so a lot like you say no a lot a lot is
going really well and
I have a lot of fun but it's
also a lot has
gone wrong no I do
n't want to hide it at all so if
you make 70 pieces then you have it  you because as an
angel you then have in your
spray and pray method, let me say,
in the end you have somehow so I’m
at you can actually say pretty precisely
I’m at the time is about
half of my investments are still
active and the  other half is no
longer active so dead um no and so
these issues are no longer active it's
either successful or dead yes and
when I look at the cut
it's actually two thirds
unsuccessful and one third successful
so roughly the cut and by  The
existing investments are divided into
about three-thirds,
one-third living dead or I have
mentally written off
one-third to early to tell, so yeah, it
’s going quite well, but I have no idea where it
ends up and and one-third together
and things like that  simply being relatively
sure to
be successful is what is all time
will say that it is the most successful
club seen from the economy,
so I think that is the highest
time actually school holidays do
n't know 180 or so about a factor of 180,
but of course it's absolutely
extremely small ticket  yes that is also
the reason why i think some people
always think
me for successful as i
am because
what they forget is that i had back then i
really had three
sometimes 5000 then at some point became
10000 € tickets but i just
always have very very  written small tickets
yes, but of course
you always learned a lot you
also get something you are in reporting you
talk to the founders, so
it's just a lot of fun for me yes
you could be wanting then you
always have to I think without without  40 Spending €40,000 does
n't really come as a surprise,
yes, it varies, so I, um, I
still see people who
sometimes make €10 or €20,000
Of course, if it's now
the hyped deal, then it's often the case
that you need less than 50,000 or so,
I can knock more and then
we'll let the history of the chronology come in,
then it was, so to speak, when
you left or is then at
some point from Ederling, so to speak
I would have disconnected and how did it go on then, to be
honest, after Darling there was a
bit of a turning point because I actually
fell into a bit of a midlife crisis and at first I didn't
really know what to do now
because it kind of turned out like I did
then I really noticed that
the money does
n't really motivate me that much, of course, I
want, I want to be able to afford a good life,
but I do
n't need any luxury or
anything else, it's
really not about that for me and  that and
then was so okay you could now
found the next you next next company
but why actually what so
I had also seen okay you
could just as well
lie down on the beach and do nothing more but
why would you do that and so me  there
was actually a
lack of orientation and
that kept me very
busy for a while, I think my
wife was also a bit on the
biscuit, but she
really supported me and
always with me  discussed and
in the end there was just my answer
hey then look for something look for
a higher meaning yes for which you
help yourself to get up in the morning and
do what you do yes because
that was a bit of a lack of motivation for me
yes and um then I
decided then many also spoke to so
um let me say social entrepreneurs
so a Raul Krauthausen whose
son built up maps.org um I
spoke
exactly where you can see which place is
barrier-free which not um I was with from
back then  MPs watch.de
so a transparency platform where you
can see the voting behavior of the
MPs where you
can ask questions to the MPs
I spoke to Till Behnke who
was in the founder of Beta place.org at the time and I decided
yes and then in the end I
want  actually do what they
do but not so non-profit but
try to marry the two worlds
you are the best of both
worlds who was that then the research step
no that was research going was to be
honest the phase where I just didn't
know exactly what  I'm supposed to do so
we had a few months ago
Science Studio Consumption so to speak
network Scientists are very
successful today so you do that and
you were there for a while then also
supported but what was
n't there then you're only then next door
step  exactly right yes so with reset
because I am the one with the first fishing rod and I
still think it’s great what you are
doing now we are also good
friends support each other
but working didn’t work back then yes
well it was I was
n’t the right person for  the job and
yes, from today's point of view it was just like that,
I didn't know what to do and
thought that would be it, but in the
end it wasn't, well, that was a
year's tour that didn't lead to the goal
but exactly and then  I've just
reconsidered and
exactly
network for neighbors so there
's also a neighborhood network,
I think there's an American model and
I suspect that he
's gone  During this internship in
99 I was the biggest fanboy of the
internet yes I thought that is the
coolest technology there is and
is it so it is also cool yes and
then it got better and better yes
the internet has made all sorts of things
better in my eyes
transparent democratic
grassroots democracy up to the
Arab spring where you thought
cool now even the dictators are being
overthrown thanks to the internet yes and then
social media and such and from there it kind of
felt like it went downhill yes
then there was more and more fake news hate
speech  and all the problems with the elevator, yes,
and that also plunged me into a
certain sense of identity crisis because
my favorite technology suddenly
made such an ugly face,
you know and I, um,
somehow I couldn't let go of it and
then I realized okay  that could
somehow be this chance this this
higher sense to show you how can
you use the internet well yes
and
then I realized okay what is what is
the reason of many of these problems is
that we are just a hammer in front of the screen
because it  it's simply much
easier
to insult someone from the screen than face to
face yes and then I actually
saw what nextor.com did in the USA
and there in the USA it was very
focused on so
neighborhood network but very
focused on nebelhut watch so let's
our  Making neighborhoods safer,
also in America, the
safer the higher are
the real estate prices, the higher is the
value of a house, so it's more like something out of the
blue and thought to me hey if you
change the spin, if you raise it very
similarly but  changes the spin to the point
that it's not about
making things safer here now and then it's
mainly about getting to know
each other
more first of all neighborhood to
help each other support each other things to
borrow things from each other to
use together
that that
would lead to that  the
internet so this we are uninhibited because
from the screen it kind of lowers the hurdle to take the
first step back to the neighbor
to the unknown neighbor
and that actually works very
well so i’m learning i
can just call in online who has
a beer bench set i want to see
can borrow or a drill then
only the three neighbors answer who
are cool enough to say yes of course I have
one come by and then you make a date
and then the ice is broken
and you
go over and ring the bell you would
never do that but without it  is already
intended so for neighborhoods in
big cities erm that
surprisingly also works in the country
so we haven't noticed a big difference until today
you would think but especially
newcomers often have the problem that
they don't really get in he really has
next to a meanwhile in Germany
Traction always says it's
really active are different are
so there are many active
neighborhoods so we have, um, we
have about 10,000 neighborhoods now
we haven't managed
to clear it out across the country
because the business case is really difficult,
no, they  So the costs are
similar to those of mobile communications, yes, why do
we have such poor reception in the villages,
yes, because of course they
don’t really work for the mobile operators and there
the radio masts
and that’s the challenge
with nebenan.de too, so
you can monetize better in the city
Placing advertising or monetizing it is a
voluntary subsidy Members
the local traders can
create business profiles and
reach the neighbors and also selected
advertising, those are actually the three pillars,
but that means there are already
100,000 people who are active every month,
two and a half million registered
users and uhm yes  almost a million
monthly so people who monthly are
very organic things right
exactly yes well that is not an that
is actually not an
exploding model yes it never was
but it is growing relatively linearly yes I
remember
there used to be flyers in our neighborhood
you thought that it was some
neighbors who voted for you,
but you had something like a cricket
campaign, so to speak, just a
neighborhood next door because so
airplanes always tried to
do clever marketing, of course,
as you know it from network
marketing  not so easy no so
that's actually the big day that
you found there then you always have to
find your big day how you
get something big
these neighbors who stand on top of each other they
really exist they're
registered on the platform and they know
and  we want to invite neighbors,
so when people register,
we ask them if they would be willing to
make this known, and if they say yes,
we feel them through a
stretch where they explain where it is, watch
out, everything you have to do is shut
Say yes, I want to and then the invitation looks like this,
I got your
first name on it, so that's
Christian from max-baer-strasse and then
the slips of paper are only distributed in the neighborhood
and
then we'll say yes and then when
people come  would be cool if you
could greet them a bit and
break the ice a bit and stuff like that but
that means they know what's going on and then
we'll help them so if we thought at first
we'd be okay neighbors
might do it ourselves then we'd
print out these notes and they
distribute but of course it can
wait quite a long time someone does that sometimes and so at
some point we said
never watch out we have to
offer it and when people say I'll do it we'll
print and distribute but what
we never did is that
these neighbors exist, yes  they are
also registered okay there are a few
others you've seen so while we're
talking about what spectacular
man that was amazing how it works
yes that as I
said an example were these
were these search banners yes and then
they were then directly on the
Land search result page I remember when
we designed it live and
started the first campaign, my
CTO panicked because we did
n't have it, we hadn't coordinated it
with the technology, well, I
just had the one who was looking for it at the time
an
all link all super parameters in the link
included yes so that just has it
itself and it has been built into the parent banner
and you can see it hasn’t been
said no and you can also see it said
uh our servers are all down yes
we suddenly have 100 times  so many
search queries I also know what's going on
something was hacked or something like that umm or a
service attack and then it came to me so
cleverly
it's just the campaign and
maybe I should have let you know beforehand
exactly
in the good old days, so to speak, again and
again I mean  you just
talked about lock old pages,
only that there are
no longer such lockout pages today,
they were my really big thing, you
had advertising on them, it also
worked really well, the
people were always there  Done ne and uh
the proper German just
logged off yes that makes I don't think anyone in
any other country in the world logs
out people do this
but the proper German just
logged off and was then done
was already
ne yes I remember been  Shopping
clubs and stuff like that, which, above all,
always take off for this job, easy
to see pages because he himself and
about 1000 or 1000 intermediaries
have collected no,
yes, there was such a monetization of sex,
for example with my video, those were
the
beginnings  yes, still the beginnings of
AdSense, i.e. Google AdSense and so
yes, where you installed the Google code on your site
and google
played advertising for it and there was,
for example, a growing hack that
I also discovered at the time that in
this one  Code you can pass a keyword with
yes and then I said
okay because my video was also
searched for a lot of people for videos
and then I just
made an adspace next to it on the right where I passed the keyword
this search with a Google
and Google could  then more or less via
Adsense just match this keyword
then also play things out that
of course then in turn has the
monetization so the click rate on
these adsen banners and I
earned
a lot increased per click yes um and so
things like that were
relatively
easy at the time  or so to speak, it was at this level that you
spoke of,
but then you
obviously asked the question of meaning and
noticed that there are other
possibilities,
exactly, so I’ll say next door  it
worked extremely well even in the first lockdown, so
the platform would
n't have existed now who invented and built it at the moment by
someone else
because everyone realized
oh crap I really need help sometimes,
so I'm shopping for older people
People who did
n't dare go out for a walk a neighbor gave
each other tremendous support in the
first lockdown it was enormous
but even now in the in the in the
refugees in the Syrian nonsense in
the sorry and Ukrainian
refugee crisis
a lot of help for the
refugees so to speak accommodation
organize but then also
set up the accommodation so if
every man gets a lot given away
exchanged free somehow given yes there were
Ukrainian families were completely taken care of
from A to Z ah it was really very very
nice to see and
in that respect yes it actually is  the
plan worked out very well I'm very
happy with that and we've sold the
majority company with my brother now he's
really already selling the majority
okay exactly we made a part exit as
founders that means we're still
shareholders but
the majority company is now Skoda
and is a  is a really great
partner at this point, so we are developing
the platform very well together with us.
I am now in the import
department, but I am no longer operationally
active
noticed him
okay there is just this
other problem that
somehow calls me also very strongly
driven by my children who
were my eldest at the time there were ten
and children know yes children always ask
a lot
and he always asked dad what are
you doing  whole day at the
computer yes I work okay what do
you work yes I am an entrepreneur yes
what is what is a company
eggs entrepreneur is someone who
founds a company and and what does a
company like that do yes so they want a problem
yes and okay  So you're a
problem solver I'm like, yes, we can
actually say that, and then yes, dad, what
is there, actually, there is
actually only one problem that I'm
worried about and then I'm
really worried that we're dealing
with the climate crisis here  somehow
driving the planet against the wall and why are
you working on some other
problem that I don't understand why why did
n't you have that yes
and then I really noticed more and more
that I was naked about me yes
because basically he's right  Actually,
yes, I think that is the most pressing
problem of our generation and I
would like to have the next one too, and
yes, and then I decided that
I wanted to work my way into it,
so I took a short
break
and then just started to read a lot
Yes, all sorts of books, that is, that of
Bill Gates and that of John Deere, and
basically got a better understanding of problems
at the time, also here with
Action,
I became a member of many podcasts some time ago because I
heard them all, maybe two years
ago, different Berlins 3  or 4 um
but Fabian Heilemann here
the
Boris here from GameDuell ne exactly um
David I just mean one exactly
right so one
very quickly hurt a lot of founders around
them and so they
founded a club as always to
get involved more or less
exactly  and to
implement the recommendation in your own company, so you have several
levers and one is basically
your own company, then your how do
you organize shopping how do
you organize your company trips your
electricity consumption your own
footprint as a company  to analyze that
we implemented next door and
then you still go to the
next scope so how can you
try to implement that again supplier relationship and customer relationship
and that um well the first
step was to implement that with everyone
and um
Exactly and then I noticed
okay I would like to go one step further
I would like to found a company that is
really so whose business model
consists of
developing climate impact yes and
then I noticed okay you are the
internet founder what do you want to do now
Solution for taxes yes this is
about the physical world it is about
moving atoms and electrons ca
n't do that much now as the internet
yes and so the low hanging digital
fruits are actually already there
other people are already working on them there
you are now  also more or less just not
too late anymore
and then I talked to a lot of people
about it that I don't
know exactly how I
can develop a grip and
one of them was Dirk Raczynski,
the founder of Xolo 3D
and so this entrepreneur and a
good one  Friend and he
then has Christian yes forget
the internet
so you are just a founder yes you know
how to build a company that
you can fundraise the network but
someone tries to find you a team
where this characteristic is still
missing so to speak  ideally in a
scientific team that
has a really good innovation,
ideally it is patent-protected,
so it can be defended and really
groundbreaking new and has a great
climate impact, um, because we have that in
Germany and all too often it
doesn’t get commercialized well, but we
have good science  good engineers
but we are not always good at
making it too big to
commercialize
yes and
I actually found that quite
obvious so I
looked around and
he then
introduced me to Marek yes Marek is
him  Inventor behind C1 yes
your current company exactly you have to so it's
about fuel but that
sounds a bit too simple so
tell me what exactly does the company do now
the company is actually C1 or cvon
yes um the domain is called Karen
why is it called  C1 because it's about methanol
with exactly one carbon atom, so
C1
so C for carbon carbon and we
want to produce methanol more or less green
we have developed a new production process
for methanol
and that the existing 100-year-old
process is supposed to replace that is quasi
disruptive new where I have one  You can use completely
different technology and methanol or
green methanol not only as a
fuel, that's one
big area of ​​application, but you can
also use it as an input material in the
chemical industry or is it
already used there today, so we are
already producing 100 million tons
of it  but just in the fossil
process from natural gas or coal
but for example the majority of the
glue in this world is made from methanol
yes that means e.g. the entire
furniture industry so Verena from
pressboards which are then installed in Ikea furniture
etc and the glue in
there  is is fossil yes that means
if you say tomorrow if a company
tomorrow Ikea tomorrow I want to
produce CO2 neutral furniture then
they would
not have to be able to produce fossils especially these glues and the
way to do this would be via green methanol
yes and the nice thing  The thing is they
simply have to switch from fossil
methanol to green methanol when purchasing and
you don’t have to do more
exactly and so first of all it’s like this we
have only invented a
new process for the production of
methanol so the founder is a
scientist or exactly the inventor
Marek  dzinski is a chemist
expert in catalysis and
quantum chemist that means more like
simulating chemistry on the computer for 14 years
you have to imagine
looks like a bitcoin mining drive
lots and lots of computers in server racks
that are constantly running produce a lot of heat
you would think since we
will  Bitcoins meant but no,
chemistry is simulated with virtual screening, yes,
and that’s the absolute expert
in there and with this technology he
invented a new catalysis, so he
streamed the entire periodic table
for a catalyst, which
is the input material, a synthesis gas to
methanol  you can implement as a
university or or was no in his company
called creative Quantum, so he is
14 years ago, he did his doctorate and then
founded creative Quantum back then in 2009 and since then
simulated chemistry as a service,
yes, he actually does it for all the
big ones  well-known chemical companies and
really solves the tough nuts for them, yes,
where they themselves don’t really
get any further and then you have
been linked and then you said
man, let’s think again and we
are now making our own product out of here,
so to speak,
Dirk was with Xolo  3D customer at Marek,
so he actually
let him explain or
solve the chemical problem and was so impressed
by the technology that he actually
wanted to invest if you
have it or not I don't need any
investors
dirk but he didn't let go and
Mark  told him at some point yes I
have a good patent here I
made a cool invention
[music]
just a new catalysis for methanol
maybe you want to invest in it
so we can actually make a company
out of it and then they
started talking about it and  Dirk
also very quickly
recognized the climate potential of the whole thing and
then added 1&1 together and
said hey, let's bring Christian in there
and then let
Brandstorm see what he can do and
Marik was open enough to say I
'm ready  I would also need
someone to make a company out of it
because I am a chemist and
find these things exactly that’s how it happened, then
one thing led to another, uh, met Mare
and then of course first of all
I had to dig into this technology myself and I
had to understand and
also have to understand the potential first
and that's exactly where we are today
you then recruited your amazing lineup of
investors for this company
so you can read
that Wolfgang Reitzle the long boss of
Linde was then the former SAP boss
Jim hagemanns fog or have snapchat
also
apply to various German
companies then Jürgen Hambrecht always
the head of BASF then in March big talk
so they are all back admitting
you got them all in there and
look here and can you do it
all or like running uh step by
step yes so  First of all,
this patent had to be financed,
so it then went into the national phase.
If you want to
patent it internationally,
you first need money in every country,
so it quickly costs,
um, six figures and international
patents to clear so many countries  So
first we had to finance the patent,
then we had to finance the next scale section
of the technology, then
we started to think about who was
still missing in this team, because that
was also what
I learned from the previous founding,
ideally you have really
complementary founding teams, yes, where the
different
skills  and areas
are also well covered in the founding team yes and
I said Marek you have the chemistry
under control yes and you can continue to
simulate that is super cool
I can do the classic CEO
tasks
storytelling fundraising heiring
organizational structure and so on but
what we are missing is, of course, point one,
the chemical engineer in the team, who
really takes care of the plant construction and
engineering,
and what we are missing is the connection between
chemistry and the economy, so I would say
the techno-economist, yes, the
strategist, who sort of  really
understands chemistry because he is also a chemist, but
can translate that, i.e.
can translate the technological advantages
into economic
automarkets strategy and so on and
can also model technology models
and so on and we
then just found the people in the form of
our sometimes Ralf der
is a chemical engineer and
takes care of plants and engineering, and in the
form of Christoph, who,
technologically, yes, he is a chemist,
can really have a say on the molecular level, but
has industrial experience and consulting experience and also
understands the economic relationships very well and also  the regulation so
it's actually the third thing you the
third circle you
have to bring to overlap technology economy and
regulation yes now
we were only a year at the
notary so in February last year and
are now 13 men so I just have
employment contract number  14 15
signed but it's not
huge yet yes so sold but not in
the research phase exactly you have to
imagine we want a
large chemical process that has been established for 100 years 100
million tons are produced with it
we want to completely
reinvent it yes that doesn't happen
overnight  yes we are talking about chemical plants
the chemistry has to work this
catalyst had to be produced and it
had to be made cheaply and scalably then the plants had to be built you
first have to build them small to see if they
work then you need them to be
bigger so scale up you don’t do all of that
overnight, right there  it's our turn with
high pressure and uh so time is what's really on
my
neck most of all no I'd like to be
faster because everyone just
doesn't wait for climate change yes it's
not even just about investors
putting pressure on me or something like that
it's about we just have to
be quick if you if we somehow
want to prevent the worst, yes,
how much money has flowed into this company,
so as I said, we
first complemented the team and then
we also have a team together with Dirk
Dirk, he really
played an important role, I would say as a
funding angel, I would call him well,
he is not operational in the founding team,
but he really played an important role
to think about, okay,
I said hey, we'll found
an AG right away because
I think so  that actually many problems
in Germany stem from the fact that all limited
companies are founded
in the AG you don't need
a virtual e-sop program you can simply
set up a real stock option program
without it can be problematic
and
it can't go into
bh-partner somehow totally totally you
block if he somehow
slept badly at night yes, um,
that means it has many advantages,
I have been okay for a long time, I want to
set up an AG for which reasons, but of
course you then need a
real supervisory board, so the supervisory board
is really an organ in the AG and
not only  There's such an advisory board
in the GmbH and then you think,
okay, who could, because we'll be the
perfect people in there and we were
relatively quick with jürgen Hambrecht
because even chemists ever CEO of BASF
hired the first quantum chemists there and their
got the computer because he believes very strongly
in this computer simulation of chemistry
as the future of the chemistry nation
and was therefore one of the first to
do it in Germany,
so very experienced in the field and
then
we came out because he was at the time
German from March and only just
promoted this green methanol strategy so cult value 0 as an alternative fuel for container ships there
is a Ted Talk from him who we
thought was very good so we really
thought about it very specifically
while
not quite like we did  it thinks
about which ones, and through whom, no,
because of course it's like that if you've
been doing it like I've been doing it for almost 23 years now, of course, you
kind of have a
network and somehow you can get to everyone via one
or two corners, somehow, no
and then
actually let our contacts play
and were able to get to the people
who then convinced them,
e.g. as I said, Mr. handrecht, I
think I also invested very heavily in this
basic technology down there, in
this quantum mechanical
simulation platform, that is
actually our super weapon because let it
be  come up with completely different things
he has to introduce you to this
green methanol process is actually
just the first product that
we want to build up we want to
show that we can do it yes it
works then of course we want to
make good business out of it and
then we want to  but also reinvest on the basis
and think about which
chemical processes you can still
reinvent because you what you must not forget
is all these large chemical
processes, most of them are over
100 years old and
everything was actually invented in Germany back then,
we were back then  the pharmacy of the
world we invented aspirin etc
but we were also the chemical
chemical factory of the world we invented ethanol
for 100 years we
invented ammonia so the haber Bosch process more than 100 years ago that was the
basis for fertilizers and that’s
it  the basis that 8
billion people in the world
can live today without but without Bosch
it would not be possible at all
all these topics and also in this
natural science that is at the end
did you then fiddle with it or
read it and have it explained and
asked so precisely  right, I read a lot
and I asked a lot,
honestly, like my children
ask me why, why did
I just ask stupid questions,
yes, and
now all the people have
invested, but there are no funds yet,
so that means we have
millions of them now  flowed in so far or
100,000 or you have to imagine
so in February last year we had
a cit round Grace 5 million draws
round there Planet Avengers here
the Friedla eh
really
super troupe invested
Power Ventures now one
Christian Buchenau and his team
we then invested in the  The supervisory board is still Udo
young, he has
built up the chemical practice of BCG for 30 years,
so he pretty much knows everyone in chemistry
on this planet
and right now in December, March
Grove invested, so the venture arm of
mask
and so we have now
actually one of the largest potential
customers on the shipping side on board
but as I said fuel green as
fuel is just an application
when will the first implementation come so you
have to imagine you have to use
this technology now we will
walk up the levels stairs yes that is a concept
that's what NASA invented for the moon landing
Level 1 is we have the idea
we fly to the moon and level 9 is the
rocket flies to the moon or who could
build a second one that does the same thing yes
so the process and
this concept has you covered  you apply to all sorts of
things
also to the chemical industry
and we are now
just before level 6, so we are about
to reach level 6
and level 9 would then be able ships
worldwide with your so large exactly
large-scale production is level 8 yes,
so level  8 is a system that
is really big and produces
from level 8 to level 9, it's
more about replicability and and and
optimization and so basically from level 8
you're actually in business I would say
and that takes a lot of time,
exactly like us  As I said, we're just
before level 6, we're already working in parallel
and that's a difference
now, ne classic, if we
didn't have this climate background then you would
really take one step after the other
because of course when you start
working on level 7 before  you've reached level 6
is of course risky that
sounds a bit like in the vaccine
so why at Bayern tag so exactly it
's actually not at all it's
actually that similar yes and
done similarly at unterkatze because of
this time pressure from Corona we said
we're already working  on this plan
and we are not yet 100% sure that
it will work, but we
simply do not have the time, yes, and we will take
this risk, do the
best educated gas and um, because in case of
doubt, we will then be in front of the wave, yes, if it if
that  If it had gone wrong
it would have been a lot who sunk a lot of money
yes but it worked
like that and we proceed in a similar way simply
because of the time pressure because we do
n't have the time to proceed serially
and so I would say risk but first
we have to go more into the  Taking a risk
that means we are already working in
parallel on Level 7, although there are
still two things that we can't say 100%
when, when, when, so
the first time, uh, quasi-commercially
produce methanol that we
can sell in relevant quantities will
probably be 20 26 yes
but you have to parallelize first
I would also build large plants that
finance themselves, like you, so
chemical park that's not
a few servers in any way, but really what you
know so much Autobahn we
imagine a big chimney, exactly so in our case
we are talking about liquid gas reactors so
these are chemical plants where the
actual reaction
takes place in a liquid reactor so you have to
imagine living in a large cylinder
solvent is in it and
the catalyst is dissolved in this solvent and
the input material is a synthesis gas
i.e. a mixture of carbon monoxide and
hydrogen
hydrogen is highly explosive  Carbon monoxide is
highly toxic that doesn’t mean it’s
entirely without safety concerns it’s
the starting material synthesis gas is
a common starting material in the chemical industry
and that then reacts in these
liquid reactors you have to imagine
that it’s also the big breakthrough so
today it’s like that that’s the case  no
liquid reactors but solid the
catalyst is a solid and
this gas reacts on the surface
of this solid catalyst and that
always scales only two-dimensionally
it is extremely difficult to cool that is
a reaction where a lot of heat
is generated and if you use it in
liquid gas reactors  then the
entire liquid becomes the reaction volume,
which is then scaled three-dimensionally and is
very easy to cool, so you
simply take back a little liquid all the time
and it also has a
number of other advantages, and as a result,
what do you have in front of you
for the first time?
What you do is
of course you try to work as much as possible with
subsidies, yes, because these
are future technologies, green
future technologies, there are
good funding programs for that at the moment, both at
national and EU level, and that
's the way it is, we have
ours  project in the chemical park that takes us
to level 7, we
submitted a funding application and
got the green light,
so then most of it
does not cover everything with public funding,
but a large part
after that the first commercial demo
you can also do well above all
EU level you can get good funding at
a lower percentage, so then
you have to pay a larger percentage
yourself, but that's
what we're in the fundra for right now, so
we actually have to, well, you
have to first prove that it's possible and
that that  also doesn't
work at all afterwards you can consider
whether you should
do licensing business out there yes because
we have patents on it yes
we have patented both a chemical driving patent and the reactor technology
and then want to
issue licenses and
sell kalisator in the long term but you have to do that
first show that it works,
before that nobody gives money for a license
and builds and builds a plant where they are
not sure, in the end
100 million will
have to flow in before anything else comes out,
that won't be enough,
so 500 million somewhere in between,
yes  so there is the order of magnitude yes and
that depends on how much you have to
build and how many of the systems you have to build yes
depends on how many of them
you get funded at what percentage
it depends on a few
factors yes but
several 100  Millions of euros, yes, but
if that works, then
you really reduce the
ship fuel industry and
then build a new Basf-like
company, so
the technology has the potential
to lower the price of green methanol, so it's more or
less cheaper than that
Today's method of producing green methanol
What is green,
chemically speaking, methanol is exactly the same as
fossil methanol, except that the
origin of this one carbon atom is no longer of
fossil origin, so it was
not extracted from the earth in the form
of gas or coal  that it
is of regenerative origin but it is
also one thing, so I think what kind of
dimensions would it be if it
were to succeed now and would have had two or three
years to come by and you managed to do
it all, then that’s a
company like biontech if  they
say okay that's crazy they
built it again now it's
really rattling and now the world
is improving and at the same time it's a huge market
or what
exactly the potential is my
blowing yes I'll give you an example
today is the market for fossils
Methanol 100 million tons production
per year World market Yes,
shipping would completely switch to zero,
so if today's shipping
in its current volume completely
switched to methanol, it would need 600
million tons of methanol per year, so
the market would
cost itself a tonne of fossil methanol for six weeks today
roughly depends on where you're buying and stuff but
roughly $450
and that's kind of like that
kind of in position
but that's exactly and that and but like
I said just shipping
would change the market for six
weeks and that's  but not even
all the
applications in the so you're
already thinking about it it's getting
easier for me because I can
access it economically I'm a scientist so not a
natural scientist
then it's already so that you're now
your billion-dollar sales company yes
it's definitely it  a real
potential is very, very big the
challenge is this scaling
because we are talking about plants that have to be built
and of course the second and the big
challenge is you also need
the green fizox because you
no longer have to get this carbon atom from
gas or coal  which
is also very, very cheap because it has
been optimized for over 150 years
is also a bit of a problem, it
is actually that oil and gas and
coal are too cheap
and this externality CO2 is not
priced in,
so the challenge is where do you get it
you get these green feedbacks because you
have more or less several options for how you can
now get the carbon atom from a
regenerative source, one is, for
example, excess biomass, so we're
not talking about cutting down forests or
cultivating rapeseed fields and then
not feeding or
eating the rapeseed  but from that
we don't talk about it with the there we talk about
waste we're talking about
sewage sludge wood waste black licker
is a waste product from
paper production i.e. biogenic waste
you can get to it but of
course there are also limited
availability somewhere, yes, they are not infinite
scalable so they are not enough
and to cover this total volume
the other route, which is the most scalable in the long term,
is that
you can still produce it later from CO2 and green hydrogen for reasons,
so you can
use captured CO2 as an input material
in the process and that
makes it natural  then back to the
business model for direct a capture,
so you don't have to inject this CO2 that you do with
direct air captures atmosphere filters
somewhere,
you actually have it, you can
sell it and you have a downstream
process that can work with it and you
lead it  it's basically in circles and you lay
the ship
or manufacture plastic product without the
new oil gas or coal taken from the ground
months here small works a series there
it was also a company in
Zurich that's there so you can tell it's
kind of attached  all of that is intertwined
a little bit together and many big
models why did you decide to go into all
these
wishes and also your personal
hope and conviction operationally so concretely
but didn't you say with
all your experience so many
companies I can also become an investor the
area under money  collect and then
invest in these companies are
led by other people, I
mean that we do a lot of people in
our generation right and left in the
circle of friends that many start
making sustainability investments and
so straight from the back who
can also afford it, of course  and yes,
have the appropriate previous life why did
n't you choose that for yourself
you'll laugh because I because I've
noticed that I'm not the best
investor and that I
've always noticed it that way,
so as a business angel I'm simply
the best friend of  Founder yes, or
from the founder yes, I
am simply very enthusiastic and
then I let myself be set on fire yes and
then I invest and then
I sit then I feel in the same boat
again Founder yes and I want to
make this company successful
and I
noticed  Whenever I did it as a
sideline, as a kind of hobby or
because I can't help but do it because it
's a passion, then
I took good measurements in the
phases where I had more time
and just thought hey  maybe
you're also an investor maybe that's
your main job too,
i actually did more deals
and wasn't selective enough and
i noticed ok that's just not what
you do professionally i wo
n't be the best really yes because you do
n't have to forget that  like them
you have to know yes you look at 100 things
and say yes 98 times no yes and that i
'm not the best no say yes that's
actually a pretty really
hard job your perspective is
so I mean that has climate change
press the time is not much
there anymore therefore only the acceleration
of the procedures a bit if you
are so deeply involved with the world and
that he also has a feeling for
speeds company building
how long it takes what if you really
do something so that  we
did a lot last year and saw a lot being created
uh also saw money in motion
are you optimistic in the end that
all of this can be solved
what a problem we are facing or are
you still unclear and I am
worried about
what will happen in 10 years
It's sometimes difficult
to remain optimistic when you
look at the science, it's
very, very dramatic how little CO2
budget we still have left. You
often grope your way so that you think
we should have
done everything we did 25 years ago  do today,
but I think we had a
few chances where we
actually took a wrong turn
when humanity
gave a two-point
conference, so I once read
at some climate conference in which
I don't even remember at the
beginning of the 90s or  So the
US President at the time would have had the chance
to actually agree on a global price for CO2, and
uh, he decided against it again at the last minute,
I don’t even remember
exactly why, but it could have
gone differently, that’s
actually always the case  History
can also happen differently and that
's a pity but what's the point of
looking backwards now yes
you know I'm reading a book
the power of now yes and
you know there is actually only
this now no that  is now
relevant and what you what we are doing now
what we are now how we are
relevant to trade and
yes, I think if we
can agree on that, so if we
don't bother
discussing whether the problem
is real or man-made or  not yes
then but tackle things then
we can still change a lot for the
better so I'm
optimistic we have many of the
technologies we need are there yes
we just have to
get them rolled out we have to do
things like
approval procedures in particular  speed up we
just have to get faster Yes,
we think pragmatically again we need a price on CO2 we
have to price this extra externality
yes the market ca
n't work at all for something that doesn't
have a price you can't expect that from any
market but it doesn't work yes
Mark can only react to prices, that
's the way it is, and yes, and
you see Germany
in a good role, I mean the cheesemaker
always against them, but also a few
weeks on the podcast, so he says
the best we can do that
he hopes for  that Germany
or Europe can also export all these
technologies to the world
that are necessary for this, so in the end
you too, yes, no, I am completely with
him, so if you look at history,
it became clear to me again that I
have familiarized myself with this as before  I've
already said we
invented all these big things, we all invented them,
so what do we Germans call the
Germans back then, yes, exactly at the beginning
of the 19th century, yes, that was really
the absolute Gründerzeit
and not just what you
know as, let's say normal Germans  So just
Benz and Daimler and and automobile
and such, but
as I just said, there are also
a lot of vaccinations in pharmaceuticals,
aspirin, all sorts of things, and
so there's a whole
inventor scene again, universities in the respective
communities, so we
basically have if  you're watching with
Frauenhofer Helmholtz Leibnitz and so
on we have great
basic research we have great universities
so we have it's not because
we don't present any good ones we
still have incredibly good
engineers what we've lost a bit
is just
this one and this one  Entrepreneurial spirit
I think back then it was just
an inventor and he then
built a company out of it yes today the
inventor is often just satisfied when
he has published the paper yes
and that's where I think the
difference comes from I think
it's just that  simply the world
has become much more complex no earlier you could just
aspirin my random invention no that
was an experiment that went wrong and
then aspirin came out and you noticed
oh that has a positive effect
and today you or you have a lot of
regulations you
you have a lot of bureaucracy when setting up
a company you you man the talent to
come fundraising so you need
so many skills that's one person
in another that's all
comes together in one person that
actually doesn't exist anymore yes you need a
team  made up of specialists who each
have the ability and that's
just much more complex to do that yes
you then need trust between
these team members so we have
more optimistic or not yes but I
am optimistic because I believe that there is
great potential
if we are
like that  Get teams built yes
and I see contacting me quite a
lot of people say hey Christian how did
you do that how did you
find this team of inventors and I would also
like to
found a company with good innovation and impact on the climate but I am looking for one
I am an experienced founder and I am
actually looking for such a scientist
or an invention and um
at the same time I believe that more and more
scientists are now considering it hey
maybe we can make a company
out of it yes um also driven by
this so who now  here there will
be some, I think, who will immediately say
I would like to found one, I have already
founded one, but
digital things,
I would like to be part of something like that, there are
teams that you
could match, so that there
is a whole one there  A number of
scientists somehow so that you
can get to know how long you have
known them yes that is not so easy
but there are ways so you have there
are more and more small with meadow yes
they see quite a lot they also
often see scientific teams
you  So there's a planet, I already
mentioned there's the one that World found,
yes, there are all sorts of
contrabian ventures, so there's
really a whole range
of climate tech funds, I think they
see a lot of teams where they say
there's something missing  nor the commercial part that,
for example, a logical
starting point where a lot has happened,
such as entrepreneurship who
have really built a great model
at the university, where they not only sit together the business administration
and and and but somehow
the engineers
and scientists who want to found a company come to
Karlsruhe RWTH  Aachen are also
centers where a lot is happening in the wow there
is now someone who
takes care of antonourship who comes from the RWTH
Aachen, that means he can also
network well there again so you
just have to see that you people with me
was that Dirk like  said no, um, without a
door, I wouldn't have
met him, so they have to have
networks that can mediate between the worlds,
we need them and
they exist, but yes, and I can
also make intros
and um, yes, I think if we do
then we can really
really get super technology great and
then export that because that
's what I have to say a little bit, so to speak,
waivers and prohibitions
on the way that you just
don't get it exported yes you can give the
children no you can now  not
increase your prosperity if you do it yourself so you
fly a lot yes I try I
try to live it well so
now I have the policy that I
no longer make suits at all yes
I only travel by train I am here today by
train
I have  I've been driving an electric car for 8
years I have a PV system on
my television
I'm going on a two-way trip more,
yes, but I no longer try
to chat somewhere for three days and
come back again, I'd
rather try just once or twice a
year somehow  to fly often I would
then yes I know
not everything always arrives yes
if you do so I am also skeptical about
setting often because I think for
too many people it is a liberation
from a bad conscience yes plus that
of course solves the clock  that the problem is
not at the root of the cause yes
epic discussion I believe with you in
our regular guest Sven
who is also always there and who, for example,
sees the disguised action critically
above all I believe
because he says nuclear power is at least
bridge technology  I think it's important
if I understand correctly and you do
n't see it that way,
I see that I actually see it
that way, yes, I um, I see it
very clearly, simply toughly rationally, the
enemy at the moment is CO2, yes, and if
it's fine, CO2, then do it  it
simply doesn't make sense
to shut down existing power plants and in parallel to
complicate this
base load that we then lack by
ramping up coal-fired power plants
because that's what we've done in the last few years
yes and that's crazy that's
crazy so if if  you so that means
you can still commit yourself to many
climate goals and still
be in favor of nuclear power that's still
surprising for many so all of
Germany yes so as a
transitional technology so sure I
think that's a mistake I
also think that's a mistake actually  the
biggest mistake Merkel made
for me yes we were also the only
country that
made a decision like that because of Fukushima no that
's even if you
go abroad no one understands what
Germany is doing there no
one really gets you that  explained abroad
is just so yes and you know that at
the point I'm not there for example they
come that so small with action is
just like that yes you have to
endure sometimes you have to endure having
different opinions I'm
also completely honest  I'm a member of the FDP
and I don't agree with many people about what
the FDP is doing right now, so to be
honest, speed limit 130 on
German autobahns, yes, that will just
make a lot of sense, it would be a
super easy measure that would save CO2,
right away, yes and  if you
feel like speeding down the street in your Porsche
then there are various
car racetracks in Germany, the
Nürburgring etc. you can drive on it and
then you just drive around there, so look,
today nobody rides
on German roads anymore, yes, that was
at some point  once everyone did it yes
and at some point it was agreed no
if i want to ride horses
go to a horse farm yes i can
continue it is not a problem why do
i have to 270 with german
autobahn boards that doesn't make any sense in my
opinion
so me  fingers crossed, of course,
as is so often the case now with guests,
in the interest of all of us somewhere that
works well and that you can make
progress in the next few years, find sponsors and then
see if you can read the new beyond text where are
you located so we're located in  Berlin, well,
Berlin has a great
science location Berlin Adlershof, a
mega success story,
Otto Lilienthal made his first
attempt at flight, so how does
aviation work, was then after the turn to a
science location, except Korn, I
think it was created for 10 or 12,000
scientists, I think
by now  30,000 or so work there
so it's really a really
big smells not mine will be the profiteer
with the trade tax but then
Berlin would suddenly be renovated right so
yes that had the bar of course extremely
high but of course if I if I
pull up yes he can't  come there
so yes thank you very much for you
come over very natural
career and let's see what's going on
everything is clear thank you Philipp Christian
great
[music]